la pause est altière majestueuse le roi
soleil et drapée dans une tenue de grand
apparat celle qui magnifie sa toute
puissance
ce portrait de louis xiv se trouve dans
la chambre royale au château de maths
une chambre dont il partage l'intimité
avec sa dame de coeur françoise
d'aubigné marquise de maintenon deux
personnages illustres liés par un
parchemin
une histoire qui trouve son prolongement
aux archives départementales daury noir
[Musique]
le document je pense exceptionnelle de
du défaut c'est vraiment faim à chaque
fois que qu'on le sort ya toujours la
même la même émotion
nommé il ya 6 mois directrice des
archives départementales de raynouard
cette jeune femme historienne de
formation et conservateur du patrimoine
est dans son élément avec un luxe de
précautions le document est délicatement
déplier il s'agit d'une lettre patente
du roi louis xiv le roi soleil
aucun décline et voilà c'est merveilleux
on à l'histoire au bout des doigts on à
l'histoire sous les yeux et on se dit ça
on a la chance de le concert avait chez
nous et il faut qu'on le transmettre aux
générations futures
c'est un mélange un petit peu de tout ça
à la fois d'émotion par rapport au passé
mais par rapport à notre responsabilité
aussi
c'est vraiment un document deux prestige
qui vient confirmer la donation du
château de maintenon alala françoise
d'aubigné qui grâce à ce document va
pouvoir s'intituler marquise de
maintenon puisqu'il s'agit de lettres
patentes qui érige la terre et le
domaine de maintenant en martyr a péri à
lettres patentes effet sur un parchemin
un matériau noble plus onéreux et plus
résistant que le papier le texte est
écrit à main levée sans rature
certains passages sont soulignés le
style est parfois grandiloquent
juridiques techniques
donner à versailles au mois de mai l'an
de grâce 1688 et de notre règne le 46e
signé oui c'était il ya dix autres
dépouilles
c'est une signature très dépouillée mais
en 1688 ligne a qu'un seul louis en
france c'est louis xiv à cadeau royal
pour honorer celle qui a été la
gouvernante des enfants illégitimes du
roi la maîtresse du roi puis son épouse
une épouse sans courage